we're not lazy today we are here and we
are getting it done as it relates to all
the news coming out of the nfl trade
deadline which also was today and we've
got our week 8 awards coming up we're
going to do a vikings packers rewatch
plus plenty more over the course the
next hour sharing let's get right to it
the trade deadline came and went today
without much fanfare as expected most of
the trades that were going to be done
were going to be done last week so that
teams could get their players in the
fold for week 9. if you do a trade today
for example the one deal that was done
deandre washington acquired by the
dolphins the running back sent from the
chiefs to miami because miles gaskin
injured an mcl on sunday against the
rams and is going to miss some time
that's a necessity trade that say one of
our guys got injured on sunday we better
do something about it trade that's the
the one major category of potential
trades that we would have seen and we
saw that because the dolphins had that
need they kept the injury quiet until
they could do the deal now they get some
help at running back even though he'll
have to wait six days he won't be
available this weekend when the dolphins
play the arizona cardinals shereen
yeah in my i was hoping we'd see at
least one big name go whether it was
will fuller or whoever we had a ton of
names that were bannered about all week
and none of those guys went they all
remained with their teams and i was kind
of disappointed we didn't have at least
one kind of splash trade i mean these
were just kind of ah okay you know
couple guys traded moved to different
teams maybe they helped maybe they don't
but they were all small deals but i do
think mike and you've talked a lot about
this that you think the trade deadline
should be moved back regardless i think
this year in particular it should have
been moved back two or three weeks i
mean we've had all these coveted cases i
would be curious if the cowboys had
another week or two whether they might
try to go trade for a quarterback uh
considering they put andy dalton on the
covet list today but they're out of time
now and and these deals are done now if
you want to cut a player pick up a
player off way he has to go through
waivers now if a player is cut so
no chance for that but i do think it
should have been pushed back at least
for this year
that's the one big procedural change
after today before today anyone with
four or more years of service who is cut
instantly becomes a free agent and can
sign with any team after today everyone
who is released must pass through
waivers and look i'm a believer shireen
that there should be no trade deadline
why should there be an artificial
barrier on the ability of franchises to
transact business you want to do a trade
christmas day do a trade christmas day
you want to do a trade now i think
rosters should lock for the teams when
the regular season ends the teams that
aren't making it to the postseason
so a team can't go buy some guy that
that would otherwise be done for the
year and load up the cannon for a
playoff run and give up a draft pick
next year to do that but i'm a free
enterprise kind of guy when it comes to
letting the two teams that want to do
business do business i don't like the
artificial deadline i don't like it now
especially with seven playoff spots per
conference because
there aren't enough teams that can say
you know what we're done let's go ahead
and do some sort of a fire sale and load
up on draft picks for next year and if a
team wants to go out and try to enhance
its roster in the hopes of pursuing a
championship go ahead and do it how
often do you really see a guy who gets
acquired during the season via trade
come in and make a huge difference
sometimes they help but i i'm at a loss
to think that there was a super bowl
champion that was pushed over the top by
an in-season trade and of course as i
say that i'm thinking boy there must be
one obvious one that i'm missing but i
can't think of one shireen can you
i really can't and you know the cowboys
traded all those high picks for
receivers that trade deadlines and they
didn't make much of a difference but i
can't think of one right at the trade
deadline that that really made that big
of a difference
of course there was one 31 years ago
that was supposed to make a big
difference for a team that had super
bowl aspirations that had everything it
needed but a running back and gave up
enough for the cowboys to win three
super bowls in four years thanks a lot
for that one shireen for the vikings and
herschel walker but other than that
there have been efforts but they have
not largely been successful willful are
not traded by the houston texans today
there had been some chatter and you
never know when talk is out there who's
really pushing it was it interim gm jack
easter be working the media a little bit
to try to create an interest in
willfuller so he didn't have to initiate
talks because when you're the one who
initiates you give up leverage you make
it known through leaks to the media that
maybe there's interest in a guy and
maybe people call the packers and the
texans were rumored to be linked on a
possible will fuller trade we heard the
sound from aaron rodgers at the top of
the program and we had it on earlier
today on pft live you know he in a very
uh roundabout
indirect way as aaron rodgers likes to
send messages made it clear he wouldn't
object to some help at receiver but they
weren't able to get it done and it
doesn't surprise me what are you getting
with will fuller you're getting a guy
that's got an eight-figure salary you'd
be picking up roughly half of it for the
rest of the year
he's got injury issues
and you've got to implement him on the
fly into your scheme and it may or may
not work it's and what do you give up to
get him you know what did the texans
want when you consider muhammad sunu got
a second round pick last year for the
falcons
and that's the thing mike they did want
too much and the texans had a lot of
guys they were listening to offers from
and none of them worked out and the
reason none of them worked out is
because the texas wanted too much i
would love to have seen the packers add
a receiver i mean when you look at those
receivers what they've done beyond uh
devonta adams it has not been good alan
lazard obviously was was having a really
good season when he got hurt but those
guys just haven't gotten it done really
behind devontae adams and they did need
to add somebody but they they just they
couldn't do it couldn't pull off the
deal didn't want to give up
what it took and i know
aaron rodgers back in the draft wanted a
receiver drafted high and obviously in
the first two rounds they didn't do that
taking a quarterback and a running back
so he did not get the receiver that he
wanted either through the draft or
through a trade i mentioned that the
chiefs traded running back deandre
washington to the dolphins obviously the
arrival of le'veon bell made washington
expendable the dolphins traded isaiah
ford to the patriots for a 2022 seventh
round draft pick that's the closest
thing to nothing that you can give up
for a guy not just next year's seventh
rounder a seventh rounder two years from
now so kind of a strange thing
apparently someone with the patriots had
an affinity for ford and i don't know
that he's going to make a huge
difference for a team that already has
its head coach making some
excuses even though he says they're not
excuses they are excuses for why the
team's two and five this year by the way
just came in for matt barrows of the
athletic dante pettis of the 49ers was
waived today they were unable to find a
trade partner for him so he will pass
through
waivers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports